Okay Google, send a message to Wayne.
I'll be at our building in 20 minutes,
can you get Josh and meet me there?
Okay Google, start a run.
[SOUND] Here's the message.
I'll be at our building in 20 minutes,
can you get Josh and meet me there?
>> Reply.
How about we make it five minutes?
[SOUND]
>> Got it.
Here's your message.
How about we make it five minutes?
Do you want to send it?
>> Cat videos.
>> [MUSIC]
>> I'll see you in 20 minutes, Timothy.
>> I'll see you in five minutes, Wayne.
>> [LAUGH] Okay.
One, two.
>> Welcome to Ubiquitous Computing.
>> I'm Timothy Jordan,
a Developer Advocate at Google.
>> And I'm Wayne Pakowski,
also a Developer Advocate at Google.
>> And I'm Josh Gordon, and you guessed
it, also a Developer Advocate at Google.
>> As you'll learn in this course,
Ubiquitous Computing is simply a fancy
phrase for technology that's accessible
to the user, whenever and
wherever they want or need it.
>> Perhaps,
they're outside going for a run.
>> Or having some friends over to
watch cat videos and play games.
>> Or maybe, it's time for a road trip.
>> Your users can be in any of those
situations, and you don't want
them to have to think about what device
they need to get to your service.
>> No, you want an experience that
presents itself to the user wherever it
makes sense.
>> By building an app that runs
on whatever devices they happen
to have nearby.
>> In this course, we'll teach you
about the existing platforms and
tools that can make your app available
on a variety of form factors.
But before we get started, I'll explain
just a little bit more about what
it means for your app to be ubiquitous.